have you ever heard of the rescue robot
a pet pal the friendly breathing
apparatus well these are just a few of
the inventions on display today at
Artemis ham Hall on the UNLV campus for
the senior design competition yeah these
are more than a couple of dozen really
sharp engineering students and they're
competing in front of a bunch of
Industry experts our Candace Charles is
live at ham Hall with just one of those
teams those are some pretty smart kids
Candace
they are nay good morning to you good
morning folks I actually wanted to tell
you Nate that this has been going on for
22 years and I just learned the project
you've been talking about all morning
drop a candidate actually came from some
great minds here at the engineering
department a part of fall design a
couple of years ago now we have even
more great minds I'm joined by two of
them here Taylor and Denise thank you so
much for joining us tell us a little bit
about your project so our project is a
rain and sun cover
it's designed to be used in theme parks
and it's got some sensors mounted on top
when we continue development Denise is
working on the on the back here what is
this part here Denise
so we have our circuit uh it's a
demonstration of the sensors okay that
will be our license or our rain sensor
our limit switches so it will be how it
works
um so right now the motor is running so
it will be like our Chinese opening and
then when our platform like hits the
limit switch our motor stops cool cool
okay Taylor why do you think this is so
neat in their community
it's something that can be used in
communities and theme parks awesome all
three of us are interested in theme
parks and we were thinking there's not
enough shade shade or rain cover when
you're in the theme parks you're always
looking for a shady spot and this is the
solves that problem awesome okay now I
asked them this right before okay before
we turned on the camera here and they
didn't know yet but you guys thought
about what you want to do with the money
the grand prize is 500 any thoughts
um
I I have no idea maybe go to Disney
World
thank you guys and good luck I hope you
win that that money of course of course
you guys can come down here and check
out the more than 30 projects from more
than 150 great minds starting at one
o'clock of course they'll be announcing
the winners next Friday we got you cover
all the details on our website
newsnow.com for now live from UNLV I'm
Candace Charles 8 news now young minds
at work love that and they got plenty of
time to decide what to do with them yeah
it's all good